Kirsten it's that time of year right if
you're experiencing a runny nose
headache congestion itchy eyes well how
do you know if you should stay home or
not Brian will breaks down the
difference between seasonal allergies or
if he might have a cold
[Music]
as you're heading into work how do you
know if you're just sick and said stay
home
or if it's just seasonal allergies
because the symptoms can be very similar
I think one of the major differences is
if you have an infection with the virus
like like covid you're you're going to
have a fever people with allergies don't
have a fever pesky allergy symptoms tend
to affect us between Valentine's Day and
our first couple of 100 degree days and
this year we can expect even worse
allergies because of all the rain in the
spring as trees come into bloom they
create more pollen that gets aerosolized
and our dry climate makes it such that
these particles are dispersed more
readily through the air so in a dry
climate with trees that produce pollen
we're going to see a lot of allergies
the best way to beat those allergy
sniffles is through nasal steroids it is
important to start those a couple weeks
before allergy season because it takes a
couple days for the nasal steroids
surely have an effect to block the nasal
symptoms from seasonal allergies
while allergies will cause a headache
and a minor sore throat if you're
experiencing a more severe sore throat
or body aches that is more than likely a
cold reporting in Las Vegas Brian will 8
news now yeah especially if you have a
fever so Dean Khan stresses if you think
you're sick or potentially contagious do
us all a favor and just stay home you
can find more details on the symptoms of
both of those on our website at
8newsnow.com